mercredi 8 septembre grande mosquée de
paris les fidèles sortent de la salle de
prière mais dans le cabinet du recteur
une réunion au sommet va commencer tous
les responsables musulmans de france
sont là ensemble ils vont fixer la date
de l'aïd el fitr la fête de fin de
ramadan le conseil se tient à huis clos
autour de la table on discute d'un seul
critère l'apparition d'une nouvelle lune
silas très visible la célébration de
l'aïd est proche quelques minutes de
délibération puisse l annonce officielle
le conseil français de culte musulman
organe de prendre la décision à
l'unanimité que le vendredi 10 septembre
et le jour de l'aïd el-fitr si pour les
cinq millions de musulmans de france la
date est la même les coutumes pour
célébrer la fête de la rupture du jeûne
sont différentes selon le pays d'origine
des pratiquants alors comment vit-on
l'aïd à travers le monde c'est ce que
nous avons voulu savoir en suivant à
paris des algériens des indonésiens et
des sénégalais
il est 8 heures comme à chaque grande
occasion du calendrier musulman la fête
commence par une prière voici médias et
12 l'ifi il est d'origine algérienne non
voyants et c'est donc son père qui
l'accompagnent à la mosquée du blanc
mesnil c'est là qu'il décide
vraiment marquer le coup et c'est
surtout très très religieux et c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très important
pour les musulmans
au même moment à paris dans le 16ème
arrondissement patrick à jim diplomate
indonésien arrive dans la salle de
prière de l'ambassade la fête de l'aïd
s'appelle ici les barrages et elle
débute là encore on se tournant vers la
mecque
anvers
dieu tout-puissant euros
toi toi
un peu plus loin dans le 18e
arrondissement raku diop a trouvé une
place sur le trottoir de la rue
polonceau pour prier c'est jour de
grande affluence à la mosquée al fath
mais impossible pour ce sénégalais de 36
ans de louper la prière de la korité le
nom de l'aïd au sénégal
c'est une journée de paix de joie la
bonne humeur
aujourd'hui à part n'y a pas de dispute
aux nobles et tous ces problèmes
aujourd'hui parce que c'est une journée
à sacrer quoi comment les gens
après la prière retour à la maison l'aïd
c'est avant tout une fête familiale pour
les algériens
[Musique]
[Rires]
on se présente ses voeux on s'embrasse
bref après les privations du mois de
ramadan c'est la joie retrouvée en
famille
tous les ans réunit on espère encore
pouvoir se réunir des dizaines d'années
comme ça il chargera
des milliers d'années
les pâtisseries les jolies robes et le
henné font aussi partie des grands
classiques de l'aïd et pour les enfants
gâtés ce jour là c'est un moment très
attendu et pourquoi tu aimes bien la
[Applaudissements]
première sonnerie de téléphone et
premier rappel en provenance d'algérie
l'aïd c'est vraiment un moment à part où
les liens de la famille se resserre
c'est sûr aujourd'hui entre paris et
alger la ligne chauffe
ça c'est vraiment le moment où tout le
monde appelle ses cd coup de fil c'est
ça y va de partout l'appellent ses
proches
dans le 15e arrondissement de paris nous
retrouvons patrick et sa famille en
cuisine les femmes préparent un plat
traditionnel indonésien
à l'origine c'est la place on a traîné
mais ça devient
nationale
le plat sera servi tout à l'heure à
l'ambassade d'indonésie mais avant cela
parents et enfants se réunissent pour un
temps fort qui a lieu une seule fois par
an le jour 2 les barrages
ça va ne passait pas
[Musique]
m en s'inclinant devant sa mère patrick
espère qu'il sera pardonné pour tous les
péchés qu'il aurait pu commettre la fête
de l'aïd est aussi appelé fête du pardon
par les musulmans et chez les
indonésiens cette cérémonie c'est le
souk émanent
les enfants se prosterne devant leurs
parents et demande pardon pour les
fautes
un à un les plus jeunes vont ainsi
s'agenouiller devant les plus anciens
s'excuser et écouter leurs conseils
une enfant en maternelle de la plus
grande
[Musique]
direction la plaine saint denis porte de
la chapelle ici c'est l'effervescence à
brac où règle les derniers détails de la
grande soirée qu'ils organisent pour
fêter la korité l'aïd en langue wolof
pour l'occasion il a fait venir des
musiciens du sénégal ce soir plus de 500
personnes vont venir danser sur du gros
son de dakar on a envie de se libérer en
fait on se dit voilà pendant au moins
c'était le coran c'étaient les prières
toute la nuit donc là on s'est dit quand
même pourquoi pas ne pas se faire
plaisir
entre-temps medjahed a rejoint le
quartier de belleville à paris comme
tous les jours ils seront à radio france
maghreb où il anime une émission et pour
la fête de l'aïd medjahed a décidé
d'ouvrir l'antenne aux auditeurs ils
vont pouvoir transmettre en direct leurs
voeux à tous leurs proches en france
mais aussi en algérie
à qui voulez vous un passer un petit
bonjour
pendant plus de cinq heures medjahed
sera au micro c'est donc à la radio avec
les auditeurs qu'il poursuivra sa
journée de l'aïd côté indonésien l'heure
est à présent à la détente comme la
famille à jim tous les invités ont
préparé des plats typiques du pays une
réception loin du protocole habituel de
l'ambassade pour conclure cette journée
de fête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
minuit retour à la plaine-saint-denis
raku et ses amis tropicale is l'ambiance
oublier les contraintes du ramadan ce
soir une seule priorité les clac
c'est comme si on était au au sénégal à
dakar quoi voilà la fête et le très bel
essai magnifique rien à dire
[Musique]
opération réussie pour raku la fête
durera jusqu'à 6h du mat csu ans chez
les sénégalais
on aura bien fêter la fin du ramadan
[Musique]